reste que gatti alors je suis décoiffe
je te dire mesdames et messieurs
mesdames et messieurs ceci est un grand
moment de télévision
ici banane imac leur cv plutôt bon je
suis prêt oui tu as bien travaillé
oui très bien tu as été sage à l'école
[Musique]
c'est lunaire cette séquence d'or petit
fils de [ __ ]
j'ai pas commencé pourtant jamais vous
vos gueules des prix d'or d'or sinon il
ya la deuxième solution évite fils de
[ __ ] se plaît à d'accord pas de fils de
p alors on tire on ramasse que certains
d'or petit-fils de dents
d'or petit fils de [ __ ] d'or et leur
petit-fils de puces d'or
igor petit fils de [ __ ] dans à produire
dormir avec ça
[Applaudissements]